[Music]
this is probably the most exciting
clueless gamer I have ever done today I
am going to review Super Smash Bros 4
Wii U this game is still in development
they don't even have a cover for the
game yet so I made one they go with this
I drew it very quickly to help me as
always is the biggest nerd on staff Erin
Blair hello sir how's it going good this
is huge right I am really really excited
I'm this is one of my favorite games I
can't believe that Nintendo gave us a
sneak peek of this and and so now we got
this thing and one of the most of you
see you Kenny - he's so excited about
this opportunity but no one of the you
can't even speak how this is how excited
people in the gaming world are you're
speaking like a caveman you're so
excited okay good we play now fire
alright so those are the characters if
this is Mario he's Italian he speaks
very broken English yes so if he's been
living in this country for a long time
he's not really paying attention we got
Donkey Kong Donkey Kong is a classic
alright and then there's Samus wasn't
this one of the guys from Daft Punk girl
futuristic space armor cannon for a hand
right so then we have zero suit samus
which is
without the suit improve if they're a
birthday suit samus knew there's a link
really Legend of Zelda going to else the
world I do know okay s Delta also I'm
seeing pointed ears she elfin yeah done
not doing it no link no Zelda no elves
so uh next is Marth yeah that's a dude
she's Jared Leto right here I think it's
a guy but you really want to kiss it
this is greninja he's a ninja pokémon
now that's a start but so these are all
from different games yes yes it spans
the world do you know about all these
games yes so you have you've got no life
you've put in all of your eggs into this
basket all right to greninja
tongue and a scarf he's like a kind of
like a frog he uses water swords so
everyone at Nintendo is on acid you know
I want to know what ideas do they edit
out that Nintendo his name's Jim job
what is he he's a blip blorp
he goes to game bar let's get a plane
what do you think okay let's do it I
want to go classic so I'm gonna be Mario
I just want to pick Mario's nose
Mario's rubbing his nipple
just trying to knock the other person
off it's not about killing the other
person you're just trying to knock them
off the platform right look there I am
yeah oh you K you I'm gonna new your
legs now that's a pong game going on
what do mean what's happening well now
there's a Pollock name is pong suddenly
makes bong start so another game from
the 70s can break out at any second
episode of chips with Erik Estrada
suddenly show up I don't hit Jimmy
Carter show up and just bum me out okay
so what happened there all right so
let's see who won oh I won
wait look Mario is applauding
sarcastically
you know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna be
the villager because he looks like one
of those puppets in a horror movie that
comes to life and murders everyone look
at his eyes those are the eyes he's
enraged because a mad scientist puts
spoons on his hands
it's the homicidal spoon hand boy
against jared leto
okay here I am umbrella wait you have
armor and a sword and I have an umbrella
oh god you got me any minute no what are
you doing in the net isn't one of those
secular but in their net what's
happening what okay wait where are we
now what's happening okay now what are
we doing we haven't done any [ __ ] why
would we fight we're in the middle of a
willy wonka nightmare oh my god what
happened who I don't know what how do
you even know who won it'll tell us oh
you won
I mean it's it's kind of simple when you
get the hang of it quick who was our
second president who was our second
president Franklin it was quick what's
his name means the villager from animal
and who's that
that's from fire emblem that's mark okay
America just lost the Wii Fit trainer
okay because I think she needs to get
outside look at her skin you can tell
she's totally vegan she's getting no
protein Wii Fit trainer vs. Donkey Kong
so you are basically King Kong and I'm
an anemic eyeless yoga instructor I love
these yoga pants
LC can fight she's not very zen
[Music]
laughs it is a mallet oh yeah that's a
huge hammer you can pick it up but she's
using it not to fight but to build poor
strength
this has been an insane experience
probably the craziest experience I've
had playing a video game but now let's
make it even crazier and jump to 4
players
I'd like to introduce Kramer okay what
do you do on the show a lot of things
yeah right so no my assistant you
excited about this game yeah okay so
everybody make a person sonar your
player for don't be an elf eye of one
allow elves should be Kirby Kirby as a
blob Kirby something that's leftover
from a construction site all right here
we go where are we
we're gonna find it Skyloft from Zelda
which is are you familiar with Scylla
from Zelda are you familiar with Scylla
from Zelda yes you're fired
tomorrow it was our second president
know in my defense he almost said
Abraham Lincoln is that what you almost
said yes check the tape check the tank
[Music]
which one are you
oh you're Kirby I'm gonna beat the crap
outta you look worse I don't even know
what I'd be suicide jumper that's it
what a chump change
let's just walk towards the other people
and just hit hey why is your eye why
should I do anything nothing see come
now you've got a big flower oh yeah so
that was a good weapon bang could have
been a street fight
grab a flower get prettier on jets why
are we on Persian rug if now we're on is
that a strip of bacon that I had a
putting green why are we on a putting
green what's this purple thing that
looks like a ghost it just disappears
this thing now I'm just hitting buttons
this is the way to play look I'm
actually doing better than that gun so
far naturally controller against my
chest
look Kirby is trying to apply but course
sadly doesn't have arms Bradley just has
to murus benign growth which wiggle when
he's excited
I said benign but so please don't write
in all right I'm gonna say I think that
this is a fantastically imaginative game
I myself wish it was simpler I wish it
involved a guy taking a walk and trying
to find a cookie and I wish they'd had
one button there was go forward and then
there was another button that was eat
cookie very impressed that we got a
chance to play there is no cover yet I
made the could you like the cover is a
great this is the cover they might go
with the pack that's you punching I do
this quickly it's at the punching or my
fist smells
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]